hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive game to share with you from
the 1988 USSR Championship on the white
end Gary Kasparov playing against vcil
vuk 24 move game out of an
English very accurate game by
casprov with this one we have a nice
instructive fight over the center to be
a bit more exact a nice fight over the
E4 Square it's a Four Knights
English kingside fing ketto for casprov
both sides
castle and ivanchuk plays
E4 so when this move is played one of
the things black is
saying is I'm prepared to give up my
Bishop for the Knight he may have
already been saying this with The
Bishop's initial deployment to B4 but
certainly
here uh playing E4 you have to be
prepared to make this capture the reason
being if white plays Knight
G5 he does the only way to not lose a
pawn which is hit three times and only
defended once is to remove an
attacker and next Black will have to add
a defender of E4 so that's what we have
Bishop takes Knight casprov follows the
general rule taking towards the
center this opens the B file possible
coordination now between the queen rook
and king Bishop on
B7 Rook E8 to defend
E4 now if you had to in this position
challenge E4 with a pawn which one are
you going with D3 or
F3 feel free to pause pause the
video okay in this game it's
F3 computer doesn't care either way
holds it around the same evaluation
wise uh what would prompt a player to go
with F3 over
D3 well notice Black's last move it has
left F7 a bit more sensitive there's now
only one Defender there's one attacker
and maybe now that F3 is in a second
attack backer might be there one day
possible Knight Rook
coordination this is one way you can
maybe look at it and another is to say
hey I heard Center pawns are a bit more
valuable than flank
pawns that's the exchange we get flank
Pawn for Center Pawn now before I go any
further I'd like to point out that you
should not treat Queen E7 and Rook E8 in
the same way in this
position there is a big difference
between these two moves now if you go
with F3 you're already lost queen C5
check and there goes your
knight all right in this game it's Rook
E8 challenged with the F Pawn e takes F
Knight takes F and now we can stare at
this
a majority for white in the
center D5 is met with D4 the majority is
immediately set into motion for white in
this
position he's not taking on D5 well why
isn't he maybe taking on D5 it helps
black to develop a new piece there isn't
a wonderful Discovery for white this may
be a bit appealing to play in this way
some knight move attacking the queen but
she has
options um there isn't a great followup
for white in this position in this one
it is simply
D4 the bishop is ready to
play the followup now Knight
E4 Knight E4 is not just about improving
a piece it's defensive in a
way instead of Knight to E4 if black
takes on
C4 white can pin the Knight bit of an
irritating position now for
black the pin could be resolved with
H6 but yeah this is a simple
continuation white can take on F6 and
then play in the center beautiful fourth
rank
Duo E4 is poison in this position Knight
D2 would Target The Rook twice and Queen
Once white would be winning after Rook
takes E4
here also know
that white could be a pest maintaining
the pin G5 to try and break it there are
sacrifices on
G5 it's avoided
altogether the Knight improves and there
is no pin C3 is under Fire it's defended
only now does black take on C4 only
after avoiding the p
in so what can we say about this
position black has just won a
pawn black has just captured away from
the center black has weakened his
control over
E4 all right from here Rook
B1 and now the play is F5 increasing his
control over
E4 another approach for black instead of
F5 is to play Queen E7 it seems uh how
to describe it it seems the more solid
approach uh it's not as
weakening why doesn't black maybe play
in this way well we have this
interference move Knight E5 and this is
maybe a position black did not want to
be in one where the bishop arrives on e4
and we could see two Targets now the H7
pawn and B7 Pawn it's still an approach
calls it around even this position but
maybe this is a reason for F5 instead of
Queen to E7 the Knight is now defended
by a pawn Knight E5 is not an option in
this
position what do you think caso's next
move is feel free to pause the
video okay it is considered the best
move and that is
G4 this is trying to pull away the flank
Pawn from controlling the E4
Square black does not bite on
G4 in the game it is Queen
E7 how can play continue if black takes
on G4
Knight
E5 Knight takes Knight Bishop takes
Knight and again there are these two
points that are under Fire
twice
also after Knight E5 if the Knight
Returns to
D6 one continuation for white is to take
on C6 you could take on C6 here there's
some uh compensation if we have um
Bishop for Knight or Bishop for Rook
exchange excuse me but it even likes
this move here E4 really emphasizes this
nice Center for white the E Pawn already
gets to roll the ewn by the way is a
pass
Pawn not a direction for black in this
position no taking away from the center
here instead he strengthens his
control of E4
now the capture on F5 and up until this
point very accurate play by both
sides this position though for black
this is where he goes wrong there's a
blunder in this position the move
played Knight
D6 what is considered best is the
capture on
F5 now why does black maybe not play in
this way way what keeps black from
capturing the F Pawn possibly I believe
it may have been Knight
G5 some ending where uh White ends up
with a very active Rook I'm going to put
on a bunch of moves here that are really
just all forcing moves capturing
moves how does this look Bishop G6 here
are the captures I'm referring to
where we get straight into an ending and
this Rook is really
active what do you do to defend this
Pawn you have to make a completely
defensive move like Rook to C8 Rook F2
if you try to reposition the Knight you
give up control of B4 there's Rook B4 to
C4 I would not at all be surprised if
this is a reason why black did not want
to play Bishop takes on F5 seeing in an
endgame position like this where you are
Tethered to the defense of a pawn where
you have this very passive Rook position
a very active white Rook
position all right in this game it is
Knight D6 so what is Black's intention
he has two points in mind F5 hit twice
and also E2 hit
twice white however has a winning
continuation after this move I wonder if
you can spot it there's only one winning
move feel free to pause the
video all right in this game it is
Knight
G5 What's Happening Here White's
coordinating you might say with his
furthest Advanced
Pawn
E6 is a hole both sides have a pawn
planted in the other in the other's Camp
F5 and C4 but the big difference between
the two of these pawns is this Pawn
controls a hole no holes here this is a
big
problem not only is their coordination
on E6 but the bishop has been unmasked
and who's stopping Bishop
D5 there's no stop stopping Bishop D5
that's going to hit and then we're going
to be looking at the bishop on D5
coordinating with the Knight on G5 on
these squares F7 and
E6 big problems here for black there is
no way out at this
stage also F5 is defended twice because
of this last move so really a lot is
happening here what black plays now
Queen takes E2
the check is thrown in the King goes to
the corner if you try to go towards the
center you're really asking for
trouble Knight check the king is forced
to E7 and now there's a disconnect
between the majors Queen is a
goner all right in this game it is King
h8 now we have Queen takes Queen Rook
takes
Queen not too late to continue to
develop Bishop
F4 Rooks are
connected and now there's IDE is to take
the Knight which is the key defender of
F7 and then jump into
F7 what's black going to do about this
in the game Knight d8 is played to
defend
F7 what other options does black have
here if black takes on
F5 here's one continuation that will net
white some
material we get to see this
check discovered
check and then Knight takes Knight
Bishop takes pawn and a piece will soon
be
one another continuation very nice one
that leads to a very nice mate is this
one here if black takes on F5 with the
bishop we can play Bishop takes Knight
if Pawn
recaptures Rook takes Bishop whites up a
piece and if Bishop takes Rook we would
have a mate in
three with Knight F7 check Knight d8
discovered check cutting off The Rook
from defending f8 and now pick your
favor
Rook E8 King h8 the only legal moves
both are met with Rook
f8
mate so in this game it is Knight
d8 in comes Bishop takes Knight at first
glance you may be saying oh White's
removing a defender of C4 and is now
going to capture on C4 and attack The
Rook this is a way forward for white
still considered winning
but white has his eye on something more
there's a bigger prize here there's a
deficiency you might say with this
underdeveloping
move this guy is now that much further
off from being a contributor it's not
defending any of the kingside squares
it's no closer to defending any of the
kingside squares this is White's
opportunity to now Take Over Control
of the only opened file Rook B to
E1 Rook exchange and now black is facing
a m in one threat it's as simple as that
it's defended with Bishop
D7 but the Rook can still enter on the
seventh Bishop C6 and we are one move
out from black resigning Can you spot
the very best move move here final move
feel free to pause the
video okay here we go
F6 and ivanchuk
resigns what's going on well if you push
the pawn well first of all white is
threatening mate Pawn takes
Pawn it's
over what do you do about that if you
push the pawn or capture on F6 that
opens up the seventh rank Rook takes H7
Checkmate what other options are there
here for
black Bishop takes Bishop is really the
only one to look
at it's going to be a mate and three
with Rook check only move is to
block F7 and now what do you do
here if you don't take on F7 with the
Knight
Pawn takes Bishop promoting to a queen
or Rook will be mate and if you do take
the pawn we would have the crowd
favorite Ending night takes night
smothered
mate what did you think of this
one anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below I hope you enjoyed
it
and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care
bye